I hate flying the lines the crowds  listen it's me  850 giver they wash their give or take  wat come to power God but Jesus God  sorry I was in an accident I was in a  coma  I didn't they didn't know who I was I'm  not a hundred percent cured yet likes  removing excuse me do I know you  what's going on here is this some kind  of a joke you know this man  you know different  everything you've heard about the issue  was my family my job and alcohol Donner  was diagnosed with leukemia is five I  spent my days and work instead of being  at home looking after because I was  afraid  otherwise you're gonna die and Gallup if  you please  I'm not a good father  hey isn't there supposed to be a good  cop hi buddy I'm your friendly  neighborhood police officer would you  like a glass of water yeah yeah actually  the two bad  you  if you have anything to say to me  anything  right back  everything's under control  got a place about you  see you sit down